so I know that you and Jen hadn't
planned on this movie in particular
being your first but what was it about
the story that compelled you to push
through and get this made and also for
her to play the lead which I know is
never an easy decision for an actor and
was her playing the lead the linchpin to
getting this made
so
we received the original draft of this
movie it was called red white and water
at the time when Jen had just begun
reading after a Hiatus and a lot of what
we were reading at the time was very
traditionally structured and predictable
and checking all the right boxes and
this was not that it was
unconventionally structured and not
particularly plot forward
not all the story questions were
perfectly answered and resolved the
characters weren't perfectly redeemed it
felt relatable and there was a mood you
could feel it when you read it and I
think after a slew of bigger Studio
films she was
itching to do something more intimate
after her Winter's Bone Roots exactly it
was a proper character piece
um
and
she immediately wanted to star in it
there was no debate over that
um and she met Lila probably two weeks
after we received it
and Lila you have amazing background in
in television and theater but this is
your first feature which is amazing
because it's a very beautifully directed
movie what was your biggest learning
curve yes clap yes
there's so many amazing female
filmmakers this season too I'm really
just overwhelmed it's such a wonderful
shift what was your biggest learning
curve in transitioning from the theater
to directing this feature but also in
what ways do you think that background
helped you tell this particular story
because I imagine there is an intimacy
that you brought to it
um first of all hi I can't see you all
but um thanks so much it's a beautiful
afternoon Los Angeles I'm a New Yorker
you're it's it's
um I'm always like God it's so beautiful
that's also true you're right it's like
what's this day so anyway thanks for
choosing to spend a weekend afternoon
inside watching this movie and sticking
around to chat with us deeply
appreciated
um
theater to film yes
um and you're right I have done some TV
although um before we started shooting
this film
we started photography for this movie in
the summer of 2019 we would then have an
interruption and have to wait a couple
of years what was that Interruption oh
well there were a few
um uh one was an interruption a lot of
other people had to navigate as well one
was not
um I mean that story essentially
in brief
is that we shot this film where it's set
in New Orleans which as you probably
know is a very vulnerable place to climb
it
um and in that first summer uh we we
moved through the flash floods and the
heat waves and the lightning holds but
there was a hurricane that stopped us in
our tracks and we had to evacuate and
there was a Jen had a heart out
um for an important event so um we
always knew we would be coming back when
we lost that time for the hurricane and
then by the time we had gotten everybody
together it was March of 2020 and I
think about 18 hours before I was meant
to get on a plane I got a call that no
one would be shooting
um that March or for many months after
how did that feel after that wait I mean
the emotional journey of coming to that
point that must have been devastating
um it was
um I will also say that at that point I
mean I would then have to relive that
moment about three times over in the
course of the pandemic I think at that
point it was devastating
it was also already contextualized by
what was beginning to unfold globally
and so I think the context though we had
so little understanding then forgive me
I'm like how long we don't have to dwell
on the pandemic too long in this
TalkBack but um I think there was there
was a lot going on uh I would say the
having the wind knocked out of your
sails is someone it would be an
understatement for how I felt personally
in that moment but there was also a lot
going on in the world
um and then essentially we would um
try to begin again and pause and
ultimately we're able to withstand the
challenges of the pandemic and get
everyone back together the summer of
2021 so two years later
um but to your question sorry that was
that was my way of saying 2019 at that
point I think I had spent three days on
the television set prior to starting to
shoot this film
um but yes my life has primarily been as
a theater director
um and I mean part of the joys of doing
this for the first time is
um was being in touch with the Deep
commonality in the core practice uh in
in ways that are probably very apparent
to you in terms of the centrality of the
conversation with the actor the Primacy
of visual composition the core
storytelling impulses the processes are
of course structured in radically
different ways
and so on a very I think basic level
um the the difference is the endurance
involved in feature filmmaking
um when you open a play
um that's when my contract ends
um I say goodbye and the actors continue
to carry the story every night
um and I think the the
being the constant the through line
across a changing landscape of
collaborators and creative processes
carrying it with you every single day
um that is the responsibility the thrill
and the resilience involved in that I
think was edifying
and Lila you intimated a little bit
about your experience working with the
actors here but I'd love to know how
much time you had with Jennifer and
Brian who's so wonderful in this as he
always is before you shot were you able
to Workshop this in an intimate setting
did they do work on their own and come
back to you how did that work
um
well
Brian with Brian the foundation is that
I've known Brian since I was 19.
yeah so I was in undergrad when he was
in drama school
so Brian is an old friend and I first
saw him in the plays of Lanford Wilson
and Terrell mccraney I saw him do
Shakespeare in the park
um so the guy has range yeah a major I
mean that's what I was going to say that
I have known for a very long time that
he's an actor of kind of unbelievable
range I believe he can do anything truly
and an actor of such kind of
unbelievable depth of spirit
um magnetism integrity
as an actor as a person
um uh so I would say there there was a
shared language there uh we had never
worked together but had wanted to for
almost two decades
um and um I think that
trust frankly was helpful and a strong
Foundation
um but to the process aspect of that
question and I would say with Jen
after this dinner our first meeting
um
uh I spent a couple of weeks uh going to
her apartment every morning and we had
breakfast and read through this the
original screenplay for this film one
page at a time very slowly just taking
our time and we were at that point not
talking about performance we were not
talking about results
we were talking
uh free associating riffing talking
about our relationship to this character
um personalizing the material I would
say and likewise building a language
that I think we would rely upon
um in environments which were less
leisurely
um but I would add that Brian and Jen
were both
um
deeply connected to their characters in
our lives
and so in the course of developing the
script
um I involve them so there there were
what I would call workshopping sessions
in which we at sort of different
intervals throughout the process in
which we were engaged in active
dramaturgical conversation about how the
scenes unfolded how the relationship
unfolded over the course of the movie
and their input was absolutely
instrumental
um to the shape their story took
and Justine obviously we see a very
important story told about the PTSD and
ensuing trauma of coming home from what
this character has experienced and I
know you worked with specialists in this
space to make sure you were telling this
authentically what did you learn even
just as a citizen of this country about
what people endure that we never
know about that we never see and someone
specifically like Lindsay
I think this is something Lila should
chime in on certainly but before you do
I think
we learned more than I could possibly
distill on this stage right now I think
one of the primary things we learned is
that recovery looks different for
everybody and that trauma can often be
quiet the way we carry it can be
internal
I think we haven't seen a lot of films
where it is demonstrated in that way we
see the physical you know maybe you know
Prosthetics or whatever injuries but we
don't see what's beyond that yes yes so
in a way it sort of felt like maybe
where we were subverting the tropes of
that genre
um but in terms of the magnitude of the
research that was done I think you
should chime in on that
um
I suspect that Justine is is cueing me
because no because she knows and please
forgive me if this sounds deeply cheesy
or hyperbolic but because
um the opportunity I had while working
on this film to consult at Great length
with veterans and U.S armed forces
service members and medical
professionals from the VA both in New
York and in New Orleans those
conversations were life-changing for me
um and the film wouldn't exist without
those people
um what was their tone when they found
out you were telling this story was it
one of gratitude was it one of fear
hoping you would cast it you know in the
right way
I mean
um in on any subject when talking about
the wide-ranging conversations I've had
I will confess I'm reticent to um to
sort of to forgive me to generalize
about people's opinions because I think
part of what was revelatory for me was
um beginning to recognize the various
assumptions that I've made as a civilian
about the kind of people that enlist
um uh and I think the opportunity to
have those assumptions challenged and
upended and to recognize that population
is not monolithic at all
um among various aspects
um uh
but forgive me I do want to answer your
question
no because I actually think it was all
of the above like I love to ask the
question um what do they get wrong in
the movies uh and sometimes it's
actually kind of like wildly wonderfully
pedestrian things actually like about
how certain badges are worn sometimes it
was significantly bigger things and of
course those answers were personal and
specific but um I think there was both
and I felt very humbled by this I think
there was gratitude and I would say
um tentative excitement particularly
among the veterans I spoke to had who
had incurred tbis
because that is really um it has become
the Hallmark injury of the Contemporary
military because of how pervasive IEDs
are
um so there was I think
trepidatious excitement about seeing
that condition represented and and I'm
sure anxiety about getting it wrong
um and as we see at the beginning the
recovery is different for every patient
there isn't one way that we expect okay
after six weeks you're ready to go back
and we and I love that we see that
struggle at the beginning with her nurse
saying you're not ready
um 100 yes and I think again while it's
hard to distill per per where you
started in terms of I think what some of
the takeaways were I think you said
something to this effect but in part
that
um and I think you can globalize this
beyond the military experience but that
recovery is rarely linear making what we
might call progress in any way is rarely
linear
um and also that
likewise progress and Recovery is often
charted in what can look like incredibly
small steps
um hard thought
very difficult steps but that to someone
standing even this close you know might
look this big
I wish we could talk all day because I
feel like we're just getting into some
juicy stuff but with that I would say
thank you so much for your hard work
thanks for not giving up on this story
we appreciate your dedication thank you
congratulations thank you for coming
have a great afternoon thank you bye
[Applause]